trato inhumano así definió daniel food
en su renuncia como enviado especial de
eeuu a haití la decisión de deportar a
miles de haitianos y otros migrantes
desde eeuu haití no se me va a asociar
con la decisión inhumana y
contraproducente de eeuu de deportar a
miles de refugiados haitianos e
inmigrantes ilegales haití un país en el
que los funcionarios estadounidenses
están confinados en recintos seguros
debido al peligro que suponen las bandas
armadas que controlan la vida cotidiana
las críticas contra administración
bailén crecen al mantener las medidas
disuasorias introducidas por donald
trump en los últimos días se suceden
imágenes que dan la vuelta al mundo la
policía de fronteras golpeó latigazos en
la espalda a migrantes que trataban de
cruzar a estados unidos-
14.000 personas llegaron a acumularse
bajo el puente que conecta a eeuu y
méxico de estas 1400 y han sido
deportadas y más de tres mil han sido
detenidas
otros han huido del improvisado
campamento con miedo a ser expulsados
después de un largo viaje la situación
de persecución se replica en méjico con
redadas nocturnas
esta nueva crisis migratoria está
teniendo consecuencias en otros países
en colombia alrededor de 19 mil
migrantes siguen varados a la espera de
cruzar a panamá
haití vive una profunda crisis miles de
personas salieran a países como brasil y
chile en 2010 tras un terremoto que dejó
300.000 muertos muchos ahora quieren
cruzar a estados unidos después de la
crisis generada por el hobbit 19 a ellos
se les suman otros que vienen en el
propio haití huyendo del último
terremoto de agosto y de la violencia
sistémica que vive el país